bernard drainville candidat de la cac
dans les villes ce de rêver le bon choix
monsieur roy vous avez bien
content de vous retrouver et patrice
gros choisi va essayer de rester au
vouvoiement pas tomber dans le
tutoiement le monsieur qu'on vient
d'entendre
il résume assez bien les doutes qui
entourent parce que que vous y alliez
monsieur de réveil pour l'amour du
québec soit je pense que personne peut
remettre en question mais de de vous
poser la question puis tout le monde le
fait aujourd'hui êtes-vous encore
souverainiste que j'arrivais pas à dire
oui c'est ça qui est aiguë fait grandir
un doute chez pas mal de monde êtes vous
encore souverainiste buanderie je suis
nationaliste patrice j'ai toujours était
nationaliste ça c'était la base de mon
engagement
quand j'étais au pq puis maintenant que
je suis à la cac il ya une continuité
c'est le nationalisme maintenant sur la
question de la souveraineté quand je me
suis présenté au leadership du parti
québécois j'ai dit écoute et l'appui à
l'option n'est plus ce qu'il était il
est en baisse j'ai proposé qu'on remette
à plus tard un référendum qu'on s'engage
à ne pas en tenir 1 dans le premier
mandat parce que je voyais bien qu'on
n'avait pas les chefs qu'on n'avait pas
l'appui bon alors c'est pas nouveau ça
que je fais ce constat c'est des gens
ont l'air de me mener comme si c'était
une 1 comme si c'est un constat qui
était nouveau c'est pas vrai je me suis
fait huer par les péquistes parce que
j'écoutais on n'a pas les chiffres et
savez vous quoi patrice on les avait pas
en 2014 et honnêtement l'option
indépendantiste les encore moins
aujourd'hui sinon je comprends non
messieurs de rêver ça beaucoup de gens
disent oh pis tu me bouchard que je
voyais la semaine dernière voilà ces
deux-là promettent au référendum
céréales et mais ça c'est une chose de
dire les québécois n'ont pas d'appétit
pour la souveraineté mais c'est une
autre chose que dire je ne suis plus
souverainiste c'est totalement différent
ouais ok mais moi ce que je dis c'est
que je reviens à politique parce que je
veux faire avancer le québec à
l'intérieur du canada ben oui parce que
le des bosses souveraineté fédéralisme
les gens sont rendus ailleurs
je suis avec eux là dessus les autos
jours ben limite patrice roy à vouloir
rentrer dans gorge des québécois un
débat dont ils ne veulent plus ça fait
50 ans qu'on fait ce débat-là el-alia
partie on peut l'aimer ou pas l'aimer
mais chose certaine il fait travailler
ensemble des gens de différentes
familles politiques qui se seraient
affrontés sur ce débat souverainté
fédéralisme par le passé et qui
maintenant travailler ensemble pour
faire avancer le québec et puis pour
régler des problèmes le génie de
monsieur legault monsieur rainville vous
venez de le dire c'est qu'il a voulu
transcender ce débat-là de dire on a
assez les vieilles chicanes on rassemble
des fédéralistes mais sur foot gay ben
monsieur dubé oui
le mieux et des finances monsieur girard
ce gir à qui l on leur pose la question
monsieur dray vellidis je suis
fédéraliste cdu bien maudit je suis
fédéraliste aucun problème à dire
pourquoi les souverainistes cette
coalition là ne serait pas capable de
dire on met ça de côté pour l'instant
c'est pas maintenant le combat mais on
reste souverainiste mais parce que j'ai
plus le goût de vous dire ça j'ai pas le
goût de j'ai pas j'ai pas le goût de
faire le référendum mafia
je devais oui même si tous que le québec
serait ultime en mieux c'est comme pays
indépendant mais ce que je vous dis - là
c'est que sur plein d'enjeux ya moyen de
faire avancer le québec à l'intérieur du
canada c'est là dessus que je veux me
concentrer gpo le goût de revenir encore
et ce débat là haut le fait assez on
n'est pas condamné patrice roy refaire
constamment les mêmes débats on le fait
pendant cinquante ans on peut tu allais
ailleurs maintenant ils savez vous quoi
ya pas mal de québécois qui répondent
oui à cette question là oui oui j'ai
cheminé patrice roy j'ai cheminé oui et
aujourd'hui je pense que sur un top
question l'éducation la santé les
ressources stratégiques là pour nous
aider à développer la batterie verte
pour les véhicules électriques au québec
l'exportation d'énergie verte vers les
états unis les maternelles 4 1
il ya plein de débats oui il ya plein
d'enjeux sur lesquels on peut avancer
pourquoi est ce que on se re pourquoi
est ce qu on se priverait de sorède
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas
condamnée à vivre dans le dans les
débats passés au québec on peut avoir
donc le québec peut se développer à sa
pleine mesure à l'intérieur du canada
vous dit le québec peut avancer à
l'intérieur du canada je vais vous
donner un exemple moi je me présente
dans les vies bon dans les vie jeux pré
si vous saviez mais le plus grand
chantier maritime au canada y est elle
est bein oui bon et là il ya deux
chantiers maritimes au canada qui sont
reconnus dans la stratégie navale du
fédéral celui de nouvelle écosse par
bing et six semaines en colombie
britannique
le troisième ça pourrait être celui de
la dvi et si on obtient sa et
apparemment on n'est pas loin de
l'obtenir c'est cette brise glace c'est
plus de 10 milliards de dollars de
contrats qui sans viendront dans la
grande région de lévis québec pour le
québec aussi parce que des fournisseurs
un peu partout pourquoi je travaillerai
pas moins avec le gouvernement fédéral
qu'avec la menace d approvisionnement
qui dit soit dit en passant que ça va
bien que les négociations avancent bien
pourquoi je t'avais riez pas avec elle
comme peut-être futur député de lévis on
verra pour que ça aboutisse très bien
donc comme future mine est peut-être si
vous êtes élue députée dessous j'ai
nommé me nève vous avez le loisir
députés là vous allez jouer semaine
espace écouté pendant mais je trouve
l'histoire du minispace que teulet c'est
quand tu dis oui à sceaux où quand tu
réponds à ça on a là notamment sur la
question ma question c'est avec les
relations que le fédéral
vous allez privilégier donc la
discussion réelle compromis plutôt que
la confrontation jo vouloir privilégier
les solutions les résultats c'est
patrice on a été correspondant
parlementaire vous et moi à ottawa en
même temps ok bon j'étais petit page à
la chambre des communes j'étais
stagiaire parlementaires à berlin j'ai
été correspondant je connais bien le
canada anglais la majorité de mes 20 ans
je les ai faites à ottawa à l'université
j'ai vécu à toronto gvk ouenza mois le
canada anglais j'ai fait mon move
étudiants soient bien vous ça j'étais
président à l'université d'ottawa
président des étudiants de l'ontario
bon je suis pas allergique au canada
anglais je les connais bien je pense que
je peux bien travailler avec eux pour
faire aboutir les dossiers puis avoir
des bons résultats pour les québécois et
fort espère tous à bernard drainville
j'entends très bien ce que vous dites
vous pourriez faire tout ça en garde un
profond des mains la conviction que dans
un monde idéal le québec serait mieux
independent oui vous pourriez faire les
deux ça se ferait il ya plein de gens
mis le feu sur l'éveil tu le fais avec
le bourhis ya plein de gens qui l'ont
fait c'est devenu c'est honnêtement je
pense que c'est devenu un débat
théorique moi je vis dans le réel et je
vis dans le réel j'ai le goût d'avancer
j'ai le goût de faire ma part alors là
évidemment les gens peuvent dire
drainville il fait son temps on n'a plus
besoin de lui sort garde et puis
quelqu'un veut dire ça sur ces gens dire
les gens du pq dit ou fait opportune fg
allez vous êtes sûr de prendre le
pouvoir bon alors c'est quoi savez-vous
quoi ont d'abord se faire élire dans les
vies 1 puis après ça on verra si les
québécois décide de donner un deuxième
mandat au gouvernement de monsieur
legault voudrais vous savez comme moi
patrice voulions mais je suis d'accord
avec vous que la constante elle est là
la commande il a l'air ok là voyons la
tendance hervé renard comme directement
les dames nord de rome l'ambiance est
bonne mais il mais vous savez que les
chiffres peuvent changer de politique en
génie oui et non mais j'ai une autre
question pour vous oui oui oui le
rapatriement totale des pouvoirs en
immigration votre votre premier ministre
dit sur nos consoles la survie du québec
est menacée mais ce trudeau trois jours
après dit non nous on va garder le volet
réunification familiale on est un pays
souverain pas question qu'on donne au
québec alors vous fait quoi de 20 ces
noms aulas bref moi je vais vous dire je
connais plein de nouveaux arrivants des
nouveaux québécois qui sont chez nous
depuis 2-3 certains 4 1 ils travaillent
ils font le parent qui veulent rester
québécois ils veulent rester veulent
s'installer au québec qui veulent
s'installer au canada puis y attendent
le sacré papier youpi c'est le bordel
total c'est le fouillis total moi je et
coûte peut-être que je suis naïf ou
idéaliste mais je pense qu'on pourrait
s'asseoir avec le gouvernement fédéral
et leur dire écoutez on peut tu re
négocier l'entente québec ottawa sur
l'immigration on va en prendre plus ça
va vous décharger on va être capable
d'avoir un processus d'immigration qui
va être plus efficace ça va être donc
vous pouvez faire bon effet map les gens
vont vous suis peut-être gay mais ma
question c'est une fois que la réponse
arrive non vous faites quoi moi la
réponse honnêtement patrice temps que je
me suis pas assis avec un interlocuteur
du fédéral pour leur expliquer que ça
pourrait dans leur intérêt qu avoir un
processus d'immigration qui est plus
efficace qui plus est plus simple qui
permet que à l'immigration de mieux se
faire qui permet à la résidence
permanente d'arriver plus vite peut-être
que le fédéral va se dire dans le fond
on a intérêt à ce qu'une entente comme
celle là se fasse et puis si ça veut
dire pour ça que le québec en prend plus
ben tant mieux peut-être que ça pourrait
dans l'intérêt des deux niveaux de
gouvernement de le faire le actuellement
on est un peu dans du politique au poste
ring le sait mais attendons voyons
l'élection si on ne réussit un tour
d'horizon je vous laisse à lisala on se
réjouit mais c'est vous avez notre
entrevue on se résume oui les
fédéralistes dans la coalition monsieur
legault ont le droit de s'appeler
fédéraliste mêlée souveraine ne sont
plus le droit de s'appeler souveraineté
je suis un nationaliste je suis un fier
je les ai toujours été excellent dans
une remarquable constance et oui mais
vous étudie berne a dit paul mots ça
fait peur non non je dansais grimpent
aux massues mais là puis je trouve qu
une cohérence dans ce que je propose
d'entrer dans votre question c'est une
question de moyens la fin est fiennes
l'objectif final c'est qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour améliorer le sort des
québécois pour leur rendre la vie plus
facile pour enrichir notre société de
faire en sorte qu'on participe à la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
qu'on continue à avancer dans le respect
de ce qui fait la beauté du québec notre
langue notre nos valeurs notre identité
ce qui fait qu'on est unique en amérique
je pense qu'on est capable de faire un
bon bout avec les moyens qu'on a à
patrice roy
sûrement mais on peut faire tout ça sans
renier nos convictions profondes c'est
une agression que les gens je ne renie
rien de mes convictions profondes mes
convictions profondes elles sont
nationalistes depuis les tout débuts et
je reste fidèle à mes convictions
profondes est ce que je veux c'est des
résultats je suis un pragmatique j'ai
jamais été un idéologue patres j'étais
pour l'entente de meech
comme monsieur bouchard et comme
plusieurs hommages voilà pendant vos
mails il n'y a pas de mine
mais ce que je pars du troisième bien
parce que vous êtes vous allé j'ai aimé
notre collègue à tva aliette le tunnel
vie en chef parce que il arrive chez
vous dans votre compte et et voilà
troisièmes lien on va parler vous vous
étiez pour avoir toujours j'ai toujours
été propre at risk toujours été pour la
question constitue le verdir un peu on
peut tu le veux
le verdit déjà peau pays une voie sur
deux qui votre transport collectif dans
un sens une voie sur deux dans l'autre
sens également ces partis au chargement
et qui nous écoutent patrice roy les
gens de montréal le vaste public qui
vous écoute on n'accepterait jamais
s'ils vivent à québec une situation
comme celle qu'on vit une agglomération
qui sera bientôt une agglomération d'un
million personnes avec deux ponts collet
l'un sur l'autre si jamais il y en a un
des deux qui qu'il faut qu'il faut
fermer parce qu'on est des travaux à
faire ou peu importe imaginez vous une
agglomération de 1 million avec un seul
pont ça n'a aucun bon sens c'est
irresponsable de pau planifier un
troisième hier dans la grande région de
québec
on comprend mieux avec quand on vous
écoute qu'est ce que monsieur legault
aussi est allé chercher vous avez vous
êtes un communicateur on vous souhaite
bonne chance bernard drainville comme à
tous les candidats
se présentaient en politique c'est noble
il ya des questions qui vont continuer à
se poser sur aussi célébrer puisque gdri
je reviendrai vous aurez l'occasion
déposé j'aurai l'occasion d'y répondre
mais vous êtes un communicateur oui un
communicateur avec des convictions la
pop et j'aurais dit non non non non non
mais j'apprécie c'est un homme c'est
beau contraste est très gentil je
voulais juste vous dire que c'est juste
communicateur des fois ça peut avoir
l'air un peu superficielle ouais je
pense que ça prend des convictions aussi
un petit peu long mais poursuivrait
saluons leur brevet rapprocha lui à la
prochaine